[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello well hi um i'm um i'm the research
director for quantum computing at the
simons institute at uc berkeley
um
this summer we have
we have an in-person summer cluster in
quantum computing here uh involving
about three dozen
people it's it's really been uh a much
needed break from zoom uh you know with
in intense discussions uh
and uh you know coffee and cookies in
person
i'm really glad we have our
uh you know my organizers for this for
the summer cluster henry yuan sandy
irani and james whitfield we have
another co-organizer
uh unfortunately was not
not
[Music]
able to be here with us
but this is a great opportunity to talk
to
talk to them about
about their expertise sandy works in
quantum complexity theory and it's a
really interesting
subject and henry yeon works on quantum
protocols and
the nature of entanglement
and james whitfield works on
quantum chemistry and how you would
solve these problems using uh using
quantum algorithms so
uh you know this is uh
this is really an opportunity to to ask
them about uh
sort of to cut to the chase and and
describe you know in a way that's
accessible uh more widely uh you know
what are the key
new developments or the ways of thinking
about about their subjects and i'd like
to start with sandy
just to pose the question a little more
sharply so in the early days of of
quantum computing
um
quantum complexity theory helped us
a lot you know sort of orient ourselves
because the
uh the capabilities of quantum computers
were so
alien to us and and and quantum complete
complexity theory helped to draw some
lines and tell us what was possible what
was not possible
at this point of course quantum
complexity theory is much more mature
and could you speak to
where
it sits and how does it relate to
classical complexity theory and is there
is there much given take between the two
subjects and what are the most
interesting
questions and issues there sure so um
so one of the cornerstone results in
quantum complexity theory
is from catalya who introduced the class
qma
which is sort of the quantum analog of
np
and he defined the the local hamiltonian
problem which is a fundamental problem
both for us as computer scientists and
in physics so the local hamiltonian
problem
describes the quantum system and the
energetics of that system so you have a
set of particles
and you uh the hamiltonian itself is a
sum of terms and each term describes the
energy interaction between a small
number of particles in the system
and the problem then is to
find a global quantum state for your
whole system with low energy or the
lowest energy so it's usually phrased as
a decision problem
is the energy of this system potentially
lower than some threshold
as computer scientists
it's a very attractive problem for us
because it's just a natural quantum
generalization of constraint
satisfaction which is a cornerstone and
fundamental problem in the cs community
on the other side um it's also a
foundational problem for condensed
matter physicists so
[Music]
a lot of
the research effort in numerical many
body systems has been
focused on finding the ground states of
you know physically motivated
hamiltonians so it's sort of the natural
marriage of these two areas
um
and there's been a lot of interesting
work um
studying the complexity of this problem
so um kataya defined the the class qma
which is sort of the
natural quantum analog of np
um and showed that local hamiltonian is
complete for this class and since then
there's been a lot of work on hardness
results
um
taking his original construction and
making it more and more realistic sort
of closer and closer to the types of
problems that physicists study
showing that you know in general we
don't hope to have quantum algorithms
that can solve these problems in their
full generality
we know a lot less than the algorithm
side so
you know there are many very interesting
classes of local hamiltonians that are
physically motivated that don't
necessarily have an np card problem
embedded inside them so for example
a natural assumption about a physical
system might be that the local terms
between pairs of particles are all the
same we call that translational variance
many of the physically motivated systems
have low particle dimension they're
qubits or you know
and
is it possible to leverage these these
features to um get provably good quantum
algorithms so there's nothing there's no
inherent complexity barrier to solving
these problems efficiently
on the meantime there's been a lot of
activity now that we have this exciting
era of of nisk computers within our
grasp
of actually using these
machines to solve local hamiltonian this
is actually one of the
potentially applications of these
near-term machines so
there have been
a lot of heuristics developed a lot of
methods for solving local hamiltonian
that look like they might work well on
near-term computers as well as
algorithms that we think might work well
in practice once we have more fault
tolerance and larger computers to
actually
but we don't know much of about whether
these will be provably if it you know
find the solution and efficient but much
like the world of constraint
satisfaction which has been you know
there's been a tremendous amount of work
honing different techniques so that in
practice many of these problems are
solvable we expect the same thing to
happen in the on the quantum side as
well so a lot of this work is sort of
taking us closer and closer to you know
algorithms that work well on average or
in practice so um
so that that will be an interesting
development for sure
um
there's a l you know there are also um
while there are sort of important
parallels between classical and quantum
complexity there are also sort of stark
differences so um
and this relates to a talk that henry
actually gave last a couple years ago
when we were at the original simon's
workshop um
you know we take it for granted that you
know in the classical world that search
and decision problems are sort of
essentially the same thing if i had an
algorithm that could tell me if a csp
has a solution i could use that to
actually find the solution
um
the relationship in quantum is much more
mysterious so uh you know you could ask
you know does this hamiltonian have a
state whose energy is less than a
certain amount
but finding the state is a completely
different question and we don't even
know how to leverage a decision problem
to find that search problem and so
there's a lot of interesting questions
around you know
when do quantum circuits exist even with
classical help to produce states you
know we don't expect necessarily to that
every ground state of every local
hamiltonian is even constructable by a
quantum circuit um so that is sort of an
interesting and mysterious difference
between the two that will i think be
further explored
so can i just ask you a quick follow-up
question
um before we move on so um
so
what you're saying is that you know
there's this there's this basic question
and complexity theory that classical
complexity theory has been obsessed with
for several decades now
which is constrained satisfaction or
satisfiability
and
the the local hamiltonian problem is a
generalization of that
and maybe it's the
you know it's it's uh uh in once once
you move to the once you acknowledge
that we live in a quantum world that's
the right question to ask and now it now
it's it has some commonality and some
differences
with uh with satisfiability uh maybe
more differences than or there are
completely new features that now appear
once you once you start looking at it so
how much of a back and forth you know
how much of a conversation is there
between
uh classical complexity theory and
quantum complexity theory or is there
you know is there more and more uh are
there more and more people who are now
now studying these quantum
complexity theory
you know so so this this quantum
sort of generalization of csbs and
satisfiability or more techniques that
are going back and forth between i think
there's a fair amount and there's sort
of uh
sort of many um
people who have been working in
classical complexity over the years are
now sort of uh
it's a natural step to start to work on
some of these problems than quantum
and then we find also that our physicist
colleagues know a lot about complexity
theory and
things to offer so um so so definitely
the conversation is is going in both
directions
yeah yeah isn't that exciting when it
happens that's great
great thank you sure
um
so uh
maybe uh turning to you henry uh so um
again
you know
just
you know from the very early days of
quantum computing one of the
one of the resources
that
quantum mechanics brings to the table
is entanglement
and you know the the
uh the role of entanglement in the power
of quantum computing you know this was
this was heavily debated in the early
days you know where
i remember back in
in these workshops in torino we used to
keep going back and forth on this but
but at this point uh
there's there's just a
completely different level of
appreciation of what entanglement brings
to the table both through
um
randomness certification and
and and through
through these uh very you know
verification protocols that you've been
working on so can you describe
where things stand and
what we know about all this subject is
now
sure so
um
in the
last few years something that i've been
really um interested in uh thinking a
lot about is the the power of
entanglement and something called the
interactive proofs
so um
in particular you know the the setting
that um
i've been interested in is you know what
happens if you have
a classical polynomial time verifier
who's trying to determine whether some
statement uh is truer or not um such a
statement could be you know is
a formula satisfiable or is a local
hamiltonian have a low ground energy or
you know any sort of
formal computational yes or no question
and um
the the verifier gets to interact with
uh two all-powerful provers
um who share entanglement
and um the the verifier interacts with
these provers and at the end of the day
the verifier has to determine whether uh
it believes um the the statement is true
or not
um the approvers are trying to convince
the verifier that the statement is true
but
you know they're not necessarily
trustworthy so the verifiers have to the
verifier has to figure out um
what the right answer is and it
it turns out that
when these provers are equipped with
entanglement
um
the ability of the verifier to verify
statements becomes vastly
uh more powerful than um
what is possible in the classical
setting when the provers don't have
entanglement and it really shows that
at least in this interactive proof
setting entanglement is an amazingly
powerful resource
and
one of the things that we discovered
recently and you know this is something
that i i worked on with um
uh you know chiang fang ji on the
natarajan tomovidic and john wright
is that we discovered um that this
a polynomial time verifier can can
verify problems as hard as the halting
problem um and this is only possible
when when the approvers share
entanglement
you know so that's one of the things
that has been discovered in the last few
years um
entanglement uh
really unlocks enhances the power of
verifiability can you say a little bit
about
in what way it uh it unlocks this bar so
what what is it about entanglement uh
uh what yeah
yeah that's a good question um
so this part is somewhat mysterious
because
on the surface it seems like maybe this
explains um the role of entanglement in
quantum computations and so on but i
think the way i think about it now is um
this entanglement that's shared by the
approvers
is used uh as a way for the verifier to
ensure that the approvers generate
randomness
um
so
so really what the verifier wanted to to
to verify
is um
for example in the case of the halting
problem does a turing machine halt right
and you know this is a notoriously
difficult problem right it's not
solvable
um
in any amount of time but let's say that
provers knew
the verifier just wants to know does it
halt or not
and the way that the verifier can get
the approvers to prove this you know in
a verifiable way is by first checking
that the provers can generate
an enormous amount of randomness far
more than the
you know
if the
if the verifier has polynomial time then
it can ask that the approvers generate
an exponential amount or doubly
exponential amount or an unlimited
amount of randomness and somehow this
randomness plays a crucial role in
checking these computational statements
great
and um
so
i guess there's another part of the
story which is that
maybe even before uh
you know we in quantum computing started
you know wondering about um this
question about
the power of entanglement where does
this come from etc
that
that the mathematicians had gotten there
first in terms of
asking these questions except they asked
them in their own
language which uh
you know which is quite uh different and
maybe hidden from us but can you say a
little bit about
the relationship and how that
how that shows up
um yeah so uh one of the you know this
so one of the surprising consequences of
this result about the interactive proofs
with entanglement is that it has an
implication for um
questions and pure mathematics that
people have been thinking about for
decades
longer than you know quantum computing
has been around
and um in particular there's this
question
known as khan and betting's problem
and this question is is comes from
operator algebras and it's formulated in
a very abstract way and it's a question
about um whether
you know these infinite dimensional
volume and algebras which are these like
highly abstract mathematical objects can
they always be approximated by finite
dimensional matrices right that's
roughly the content of the question they
were asking
um and you know when they formulated
this they weren't thinking of
interactive proofs or turing machines or
quantum entanglement or things like that
but the surprising thing is that the
fact that
these interactive proofs with
entanglement are so powerful actually
gives an answer to uh this this operator
algebra's question
and um you know the connection between
the two is pretty surprising
um and uh you know it kind of goes
through this long winding road and it
but
but you know now we have this connection
and one of the the
things that people are trying to
understand including myself
um is
really
what goes on with this connection and
why is it there and what what's
essential and what's not essential yeah
that's fascinating
oh great
um
so uh
turning to you james uh so you you work
in uh quantum chemistry which is which
is
quite a
you know which which means that you
bring to this to the table both your
expertise in
in chemistry as well as quantum
computation so
and you're you're thinking about uh
questions about um uh what kind of
algorithms you know what how are we
actually going to use quantum computers
and this is one of the most
most promising directions that we think
of quantum simulation can you say what's
uh you know there's a lot to say about
uh this field but can you describe to us
yeah i think it's really exciting where
quantum computing is now i mean with the
advent of nisk scale quantum computers
we now have this opportunity to use
quantum devices in ways that we've only
talked about in theory like you were
mentioning earlier a lot of these ideas
have come up a long time ago people have
been developing but now we actually have
the devices actually go play and see if
it actually works
and i think it's really fascinating you
know trying to build up the theory of
like you said computational complexity
where you have this question of if we
built a quantum computer is there
something practical we can do with it
and what should we not aim to do it or
what should we aim to do with it i think
that's a lot of things that really drag
me into this area of quantum complexity
to start thinking about what are some of
the limits and how do i understand them
and bring them back into quantum
chemistry bring them back into quantum
and back into computational physics and
how do we actually understand how to
simulate things what we should be trying
to simulate what we shouldn't be trying
to simulate um one of the recent results
we had actually was sandy as well as
some other co-authors from the simons
institute
was thinking about what are some of the
features of electronic structure
problems that make them difficult
to simulate going back to this qma
question
and so a lot of what i've been thinking
about a lot of what's been driving my
work is thinking about can we actually
reach quantum supremacy in a way that's
practical right so a lot of the efforts
around quantum supremacy around very
theoretical models random circuit
sampling
boson sampling a lot of sampling
problems but how do we go back and apply
this to quantum chemistry can we go back
and apply to quantum chemistry can we
understand how these algorithms can be
used to understand something about the
physical world around us i think this is
a large push for why people even develop
quantum computers in the first place and
i think now we're getting to the point
we can see that can be realized can we
realize now do we need to wait longer if
it does get realized how well is it
realized is it a huge difference does
machine learning
able to enter into this conversation in
a way that's useful and in in
interesting to also be able to pair
these things up we've talked a lot at
science institute about machine learning
about
quantum complexity quantum computation
but then trying to see how these things
all go back and apply to computational
problems how do we actually take these
algorithms and actually see if they can
actually improve what's what's being
done now i think that's the right way to
understand quantum supremacy when we can
do something practical as well um not
just theoretically
i see and i i i would uh
i would imagine that um
this is particularly hard in
quantum chemistry given that there's
there's this
long history of uh
of uh
techniques and tricks and that people
you know chemists have been have been
very busy over many decades finding
finding really
efficient classical ways of getting out
answers so can you see a little bit
about that yeah i can say some really
interesting things i think with simon's
institute having very heavy emphasis on
computation you also note that alan
turing's papers before you have digital
computers as well um computational
chemistry also starts off before you
have digital computers um hartree from
archery focusing actually cites a
computer but it's from the naval uh
royal the royal observatory um so it was
a person who just did the computation by
hand oh that's right the computer that's
right that's right yeah right
flexibility is a totally different thing
when you have a pencil paper so yeah
also programming right dynamic
programming it was pencil and paper
quality control same thing you have five
you know competition engineers doing the
problems
that you can see already tightly
intertwined right so i just apology
already come into quantum chemistry
talking about whether molecules are
connected or not you have graph theory
entering into you know molecular
structures and things of this nature you
have a lot of questions from local
hamiltonian problems entering into what
are the ground states of these problems
you have questions about
how does this interact with one another
you have open system questions you have
so many interesting things that come in
and with
a large area you can talk about higher
energy physics you can talk about field
theories you can go all the way down to
you know low energy theories like
quantum chemistry they're talking about
balance reactions things of this nature
that really give us a nice way to
understand what computers can and can't
do and i think that's really where this
understanding of what theoretically a
computer is helps us understand what we
can do practically and i think it's it's
a two-way conversation
actually speaking of the conversation uh
you you said you and sandy and others
here the simon institute started on this
collaboration
uh in our in our semester-long program
last year the one
where we
sort of seem to have missed a year and
something but then we are continuing uh
after after a break uh that was
enforced upon us but maybe going back to
that time when you started the
collaboration can you can you say what
it took to
to sort of break to
cross these disciplinary boundaries and
how did you get together over this is
there
um
yeah i mean i guess i think there's
there's an aspect of it that
the simon institute really brings
together people with very different
expertise gives people a good chance to
mix and talk and discuss things and so
it was really nice they just said hey
what are you what are you thinking about
and then we just started discussing from
there and started building out what are
some interesting ideas what are some
interesting points of overlap what are
some problems we can actually make
progress on and kind of define it that
way over the course of almost a year
right right yeah so we met over zoom
and then just kind of resumed our weekly
meetings here in person
so you started in person
switch to zoom and then back to being in
person but you know i'm interested in
you know uh the complexity when are
local hamiltonians hard um and you know
it's sort of an open question these very
specialized hamiltonians that come from
molecular structure do they remain hard
or is there enough structure to actually
solve them efficiently so it it made a
lot of sense to sort of
you know
talk to someone who who is
has some you know field knowledge of
this
this area so it was kind of a natural
collaboration so that's really really
nice yeah
um can i ask a question yeah so i'm i'm
kind of curious so i guess you've come
from the chemistry of your background in
chemistry chemistry was my first degree
so and so in in the world of chemistry
how do chemists think about quantum
computers or i mean are they all excited
about it or um
what's the yeah it's a that's a great
way uh great question i think
there is
excitement but a lot of people are also
very practical from quantum chemistry
from the community of chemists right
they're really interested in something
that works so a lot of people are paying
attention and it's a question of whether
or not it's worth the investment yet
right so these noises intermediate scale
quantum computers really aren't going to
solve any problems yet so i think it's
more people are just keeping their ear
to the ground to see what's going on at
acs there's always a workshop about
quantum computing when people come and
talk about what's what's the latest and
greatest right you have a lot of efforts
going on instead of variational quantum
algorithms that's really around building
quantum chemistry algorithms out there's
a lot of the code that's been built for
um
for using quantum computers has been
around quantum chemistry as well there's
been a lot of things to import a lot of
the classical methods into quantum so i
i don't know that it's going to that
it's convincing
that
you know a bench chemist is going to
learn how quantum computer works but it
might be the case that a bench chemist
would use a quantum computer would never
know it right so if we start having
packages that's sophisticated enough to
run
quantum algorithms without anyone
knowing then
which one is a better answer you don't
actually care about how it got there you
just want the the better
more accurate answer yes there's a lot
of computational chemistry that's down
to making tool sets and you make the
tool set and then the person who wants
to build something just grabs a hammer
and gets to work they don't need to know
all the internals of it and i think
that's how quantum computing will be
used utilized primarily i mean with the
the advent of so many online
access points to quantum computers no
one's having a personal quantum
computing program locally so that it's
going to be all cloud-based and then if
you're doing cloud-based computational
chemistry you might as well call quantum
computer why you're calling a cloud
server
actually we're just following up on that
um
you know
uh in in various areas you know
maybe condensed matter physics you know
there are there are these quantum
inspired classical algorithms you know
just just thinking about quantum
computation has helped inspire a
different way of doing classical
computation so is there much of that in
chemistry
yet oh there has been plenty um i think
we're discussing entanglement and
entanglement structure gives rise to
this beautiful theory of matrix product
states and tensor networks and a lot of
these tensor network decompositions have
been applied to quantum chemistry in
fact they're being applied to quantum
quantum chemistry so quantum algorithms
around doing improved decompositions but
a lot of this is around understanding
how entanglement actually constrains
your computational power so i think when
you have um
certain aspects of your hamiltonian that
make it easy to simulate or perhaps
doesn't generate a large amount of
entanglement then you can do a lot of
trick sex you get away with a lot of
things
that's that's fascinating
can i turn to something else uh you
you've been involved in in a lot of
education efforts in quantum computing
reaching beyond the university can you
speak a little bit to that given the
great amount of general interest in the
subject yeah i can say um yeah it's been
really fascinating to watch quantum
computing grow and really think about
how to explain quantum computing in
better and better ways
my first phd student to graduate canal
cetia started a company cuberate shortly
after graduated and before we even
started that company part of it comes
out of the separates that we're doing at
dartmouth to just think about quantum
computing in very open spaces and very
fun ways that you can kind of come play
learn and go on
we had a pizza and programming
experience on campus where there was
pizza after in the afternoon
some
researchers from ibm had came to
dartmouth's college and we just kind of
sat around and everyone got a chance to
just play on computers there was some
pre prefab quantum algorithms to work on
and there was some discussion everyone
could walk around and talk very open
learning environment
learn whatever you wanted and then
that turned into making an online
platform for people to learn
where people could just play around with
different quantum algorithms and just
play around and just kind of explore and
so
out of that came this idea of cuberate
which is a company that actually sandy's
on the board
and this cube right company has done a
lot of efforts to help make quantum
computing accessible to allow people to
explore quantum computing
we deployed it instead of several summer
schools we've used it at a local high
school inside of hanover new hampshire
and um
you know it's a very nice place to start
learning quantum computing and in from
there i've been involved in several
other organizations that are doing a lot
of quantum outreach so
um ibm has an hbcu center where they're
working with historically black colleges
universities and i'm on the board there
cuba by cubit which is a coding school
where they're doing a lot of information
for high school students they've
actually gotten their high school
classes accredited for um high school
students that are taking it to go to
their principals and actually get
high school credit for it so that's also
been really impressive to be on the the
advising board there yeah i guess we
just helped these things grow well i
became a fan of hubrid because i used it
in my undergraduate class so i had 75
really enthusiastic undergraduate
students learning about quantum
computing and so i designed the labs and
used q-brain and it was great because i
couldn't assume any prior programming
experience because they were coming from
different departments and but it was
sort of a level playing field everyone
could sort of get on and get running
right away so it was very very nice
platform to use so yeah so this is this
is uh you know that's that's the
experience i've had too with the
quantum computing classes that this
somehow there's a
unusually high degree of interest in in
themselves yeah this is a general uh
they were nominated we were very excited
so um you know
it was an upper division class so they
chose to take it but to have 75 really
enthusiastic hours so this was all
online because that's you know that was
the state of the world at the moment um
my online office hours were packed not
just asking about how do you do problem
number three on the homework but just
with all kinds of interesting questions
about you know quantum computing in
general so it was a fun class to teach
and they really enjoyed kind of the
hands-on
i think
you know some students learn better with
pencil and paper and some guy have to
get in and do a little coding before
they really really grasp it so it was
great to have both in the class
it's fun
yeah i so the in this last spring i
taught a class and there was also a lot
of interest and i was just thinking like
when i took my first quantum computing
class 10 years ago it was a very
different
world
the teacher was struggling to get you
know more than 10 people
and now i was teaching there's a waiting
list that was as long as as large as the
class yeah it was very different times
yeah
oh it's like very exciting yeah
well thank you very much this was this
was a really fun conversation yeah
thank you thank you it's good to be here
[Music]
you